HE'S FINE AFTER THE GAME.
WE SAW HIM AFTER THE G THE
TEAM.
LINGREN LIFTS IT AHEAD.
THE PASS TOO BROKEN UP.
NICE PLAY BY PANARIN.
COMING BACK.
GOOD PLAYS
IN THE DEFENSIVE ZONE.
DOES IT AGAIN FOR T
AND JESPER  IN FRONT.
SHOT, SASATHERE'S ONE.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE. OF THE NET.
TATAR WILL BRING IT UP. PUCK, R.
IT DID. GOODROW.
THAT SHOT, SCORE.
DOUGIE HAMILTON.
AND NOW, HE'S GOT GOES DOWN.
HE WAS BUMPED.
A SHOT.
BLOCKED MOVES IN.
GOODROW MOVES IT BIG-TIME MOVE.
RANGERS CYCLING.
STROME CONTROLLING. HAD TWO.
AND THE PASS FOR ZIBANEJAD A RE.
COULDN'T GET THE P PANARIN, FOX.
NOW, STROME IS HEADING OFF.
>> Sam: THE
>> Sam: NOW, DAWSON SHOOT-OUT A
ALEXEI
SHOOT-OUT.
TOMAS TATAR, FOR THE DEVILS.
MOVES IN ON
ABLE TO KICK IT
C